[موسيقى]
قبل قليل يعني قبل دقائقنا الان تم
الاعلان عن انقاذ طفله في ولايه كهرمان
مرعش صمدت تحت الانقاض لمده تسع وتسعين
ساعه تم اخراجها قبل قليل لكن مع هذه
المحاولات دائما هناك مع الاسف اعداد
الضحيه تستمر
وهناك انتشال للجثث في هذا الموقع الذي
نتواجد فيه الان
[موسيقى]
وبدات عمليات
الحفر بالاليات الثقيله يحاولون يعني
ازاله ما يمكن ازالته من هذه الانقاذ
ليتمكنوا من الوصول الى
العالقين في هذا المبنى
[موسيقى]
لا يمكنهم الوصول الى المنتصف الا بعد
ازاله بنايه والتي تليها لانه البنايات
حينما سقطت تداخلت في بعضها البعض واصبحت
كارثه حقيقيه وبالتالي هنالك تحديات كبيره
هنالك ابنيه كثيره جدا مهدده وايله للسقوط
[موسيقى]
المشكله اتت على مدينه برمتها فقلبتها ما
كان فوق الارض اصبح تحت الارض لما لا
كهرباء
[موسيقى]
التركيز الاكبر على يعني البحث عن رجيم
متوقعين تحت الانقراض وتحديدا في سلقين
وفي جنديرس التي لا تزال يعني حوالي 50
مبلغ مدمر لم يشملها جهود البحث ولا حتى
الانقاذ
[موسيقى]